Yesterday, I told you with all the normal
disclaimers and caveats that a new CNN poll
has Donald Trump down by a historic 14 points
to Joe Biden in national presidential election
polling.
Fifty five to forty one.
Now, this is important not just because the
14 point lead is unconscionable, but it's
also important because a challenger hitting
50 percent so regularly five months before
the election is not very common.
Donald Trump has had an absolutely wild tantrum
in response.
And I want to give you a look at what he said
and then we can fact check it.
So Trump has been reportedly going nuts on
his campaign manager, Brad Parr, scale.
How could I be losing to Biden?
How could these polls be true?
We talked yesterday about this Zoome call
during which Corey Lewandowsky asked, what
exactly is our message for reelection in November?
And this all led to Donald Trump having a
tantrum tweeting, quote, CNN polls are as
fake as they're reporting.
Same numbers and worse against crooked Hillary
Dems would destroy America.
So there are two empirical claims being made
there.
The first is CNN.
Polling is bad.
Trump calls it fake.
The second is that his numbers were even worse
against Hillary in 2016 than they are today
against Biden.
And yet he still managed to win in 2016.
So this is a great opportunity to just examine
empirical claims.
First, is CNN a good pollster or a bad pollster?
Remember, the polling arms of a lot of these
media outlets are separate from the reporting
or broadcast arm.
So, for example, Fox News polling is actually
quite good despite Fox News Channel being
a right wing hack job.
CNN polls are also well ranked.
They're ranked B plus by 538.
So CNN polling is quite good.
Trump's claim that CNN polling is bad is incorrect.
Second claim from Trump is that he was polling
even worse against Hillary in 2016 and he's
still won.
That's simply not true.
If we go back and look at June of 2016, meaning
five months before the 2016 election, just
as right now we're five months out.
You can see if you're watching that the with
the exception of one or two outliers, Hillary
Clinton was more or less polling four points
ahead of Trump.
And reminder, she did win the popular vote
against Trump by a couple of points.
If you look at the polling of Trump versus
Hillary right before the election, you can
see it was even.
Loeser Hillary was ahead by three point two
on Election Day and she won by two point one
because remember, these are popular vote polls.
So Trump is wrong on both counts.
He's losing to Biden now by more than he was
losing to Hillary.
And CNN is a pretty good pollster, but it
doesn't really matter because this is all
narrative.
It's what can you tell your supporters that
will get them fired up?
And fake news.
CNN is lying to you.
Gets his supporters fired up.
Last thing, Trump then tweeted that he has
hired a pollster to debunk the CNN poll because
he was clearly so triggered by it.
Tweeting, I have retained highly respected
pollster McLaughlan and Associates to analyze
today's CNN poll and others, which I felt
were fake based on the incredible enthusiasm
we are receiving.
Read analysis for yourself.
This is the same thing they and others did
when we defeat defeated crooked Hillary in
2016.
They are called suppression polls and are
out to dampen enthusiasm despite three and
a half years of phony witch hunts.
We are winning and we will close it out on
November 3rd.
Again, the letter Trump posted with this analysis
is all wrong.
The McGlaughlin memo wrongly states that the
CNN poll finding Biden up 14 is from an all
adults sample.
That's not true.
CNN says very clearly in the methodology it
is a registered voter sample.
So even the analysis of the poll that Trump
paid for is bogus.
So the final message, this election is nowhere
near over.
This is going to be a fight.
Every voter should assume Trump can win their
state.
And you should operate on that basis.
This is a big gap.
So certainly Trump will, number one, need
a credible story as to.
Here's how I am fixing the economy.
Here is how I am dealing with the corona virus.
Well, because otherwise he's not going to
be able to turn it around.
So expect that story to be told.
It'll probably be a story of rehabilitation
of the American economy.
And number two, Biden probably needs to mess
up at this point in order to squander the
lead.
But both of those things can happen.
We can't be complacent.
We all have a role to play.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.